[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
today we're going to be discussing
voldemort's tyrannical reign in the
second wizarding war
hogwarts hogwarts first-year students
and ones let's dive into it
voldemort's regime during the second
wizarding war really flipped the
wizarding world on its axis
where once there was peace now there was
heartbreak separation and destruction
he had successfully taken over the
ministry of magic torn apart diagonally
and even managed to breach the walls of
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry the world's foremost magic
school
the school which had previously been
overseen by a powerful wizard and good
guy maybe albus dumbledore was no longer
under his protection after his untimely
death
dumbledore's vacancy left a big hole in
hogwarts and without his protection it
didn't take long for voldemort and the
death eaters to waltz right in but the
death eaters taking over hogwarts
certainly didn't mean that classes would
stop oh no
class was still very much in session
just with a very different set of rules
and approach with a double agent snape
taking the headmaster helm most of the
school staff remained in their usual
postings however a death eater takeover
did of course mean that a few new faces
were introduced to the faculty like
alecto and amicus caro a pureblood
brother-sister combo that took over
muggle studies and defense against the
dark arts respectively okay silas we get
it class was still in session what's
your point well school in session meant
that new faces were still popping up at
hogwarts that's right just like harry
potter in his first year new bright
young witches and wizards were walking
through the doors of hogwarts for the
very first time
but can you even begin to imagine how
much different this experience would
have been for these new first years
harry was met with wonder magic and
excitement
these new first years must have been met
with darkness terror and uncertainty
entirely unsure of where the school
stood amidst voldemort's wizarding world
takeover
why were students even sent
well as it turns out new ownership meant
new rules
attendance is now compulsory for every
young witch and wizard lupin replied
that was announced yesterday it's a
change because it was never obligatory
before of course nearly every witch and
wizard in britain has been educated at
hogwarts but their parents had the right
to teach them at home or send them
abroad if they preferred
this way voldemort will have the whole
wizarding population under his eye from
a young age and is also another way of
weeding out muggleborns because students
must be given blood status meaning that
they have proven to the ministry that
they are of wizard descent before they
are allowed to attend
imagine a young wizard bright-eyed and
eager to learn walking into the
dystopian version of hogwarts reserved
for nightmares if we're going to be
completely real here hogwarts was
basically a prison at the time
it was compulsory to attend students
were getting chained up in the dungeon
and if you got detention it's likely
that you'd be crucio'd and this doesn't
even begin to factor in the trauma that
first year muggleborns would have faced
the biggest victims of all
hopefully the muggleborns were smart
enough to just stay home
because realistically they would have
almost certainly faced imprisonment or
death
but for those students that did approach
this like a normal school year
circumstances aside my question is how
did they source their school supplies
specifically how did they source their
ones
as soon as the half-blood prince diagon
alley had been terrorized
ollivander was missing and his one shop
had closed down how are students meant
to procure supplies
ones are one of the most important
scratch that the most important part of
a witch or wizard's arsenal so there's
got to be some kind of explanation here
interestingly book 7 does seem to
introduce that there is some level of
new want legislation
but things are certainly still a little
unclear does the ministry have
possession of ones releasing them only
to those with verification of blood
status or have ollivander's ones been
ransacked by the death eaters we do know
that bellatrix gets another wand after
all
well as it turns out this question is
somewhat addressed in some dialogue
between lupin arthur and ginny in the
half bud prince when word first gets out
that ollivander had been kidnapped ginny
asks how her people will get ones
talking of diagon alley said mr weasley
looks like ollivander's gone too
the wand maker said ginny looking
startled that's the one shops empty no
sign of a struggle no one knows whether
he left voluntarily or was kidnapped but
once what will people do for ones
they'll make do with other makers said
lupin but ollivander was the best and if
the other side of got him is not so good
for us
what this means is that first years
could have had their pick of any of the
other one shops assuming they weren't
closed too
however it does also mean that they
would have to settle for sub-par ones
assuming there is some merit to the
whole ollivander's ones the best elitist
mentality this also kind of checks out
because why would voldemort care whether
or not first year students had access to
the best of the best when it came to
ones if you guys want me to make a video
on the history of all known wand makers
then let me know by leaving a comment
down below
okay so first years had to attend
hogwarts due to new legislation and they
were able to source ones through other
wand shops but can we just talk about
the experience they probably had
how would they ever be able to just
shrug it off and go back to school the
following year
pov you're a muggle worn you are
entirely unaware of your magical
abilities all the fact that magic is
real for that matter you've never heard
of hogwarts you didn't know there was a
wizarding world and you just turned 11.
a letter comes in the mail hogwarts
school of witchcraft and wizardry
interesting you begin to read and you
start to see the words witch wizard and
magic appear on a page more than you've
ever seen before
the letter is interesting but without
mcgonagall visiting to explain how
things work it's hard to make sense of
it but wait what's this
compulsory attendance
your life as you know it gets uprooted
and all of a sudden you're forced into
attendance at a magical school
you're apprehensive but your parents
come to the consensus that the letter is
legitimate and that you should be sent
away
this is where the journey begins you
show up at hogwarts the rhyme age of 11
more intimidated by this new environment
than anyone could ever imagine
there are whispers among students that
things are very different this year but
you don't know what they mean
things escalate quickly you're sorted
into a house and then immediately
punished along with many others simply
for existing as a muggleborn
chained up in the dungeons and tortured
by alleged professors with the cruciatus
curse you remain stuck there until
voldemort is finally defeated
my question is after the whole voldemort
conflict had ended how could hogwarts
staff the good ones reasonably expect
these types of students to come back
how did hogwarts recover the school had
been physically destroyed yes but that
was fixable its reputation on the other
hand would be much harder to fix
how could parents of younger students
ever put their trust in the school again
when it came to the safety of their
students
how could muggleborns who showed up and
received instant torture ever put their
faith in hogwarts
while the second wizarding war may have
ended with voldemort's defeat you can be
sure that the wizarding world took a
long time to recover
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember
it does not do to drill on dreams and
forget to live